Et bien bonjour au peuple des internet et bienvenue dans cette sixième
attend j'en prend soin c'est très précieux dans cette sixième vidéo du 6 décembre de ce
mental vlogmas
calendrier de l'avent youtube
aujourd'hui
il y a un livre que j'aime particulièrement
et on va parler de ce livre parce qu'il ya des trucs vraiment intéressant et drôle dedans
je l'ai rangé précieusement dans cette petite mallette
*musique*
mon dieu
Mais c'est presque magique
mais comment faisait elle pour rentrer dedans ? c'est beaucoup trop gros c'est des
effets spéciaux de malade je vous ai niqué les oreilles parce que le micro est là et ça fait aussi plaisir
avant de parler du livre en lui-même et de vous rappeler que c'est pas un placement produit je vous je vous recommande également les deux
anciens livres de la même collection sont 50 anecdotes
50 drôles d'anecdotes scientifiques pour calmer un peu les bacs +12 et 50 drôles d'anecdotes
historiques pour se la raconter dans les dîners
et ces bouquins j'en avais déjà parlé un petit peu sur la chaîne ils viennent de sortir un troisième tome qui s'appelle 50 drôles d'anecdotes
savantes pour estomaquer ceux qui la ramène trop t'as vu c'est étrange quand je parle près de la lampe on m'entend vachement mieux c'est quand même bizarre
qui se passe dans ce bureau c'est un petit peu incroyable
alors
dans le livre on a des titres dans le sommaire qui ressemblerait presque à des vidéos YouTube
respirer donne le cancer
l'internet est contrôlé par sept personnes qui possèdent sept clés, le paradoxe du menteur est faux, le kilo se trouve en France
Elle a inventé la pire odeur du monde
vraiment le l'auteur Fred Royer peut ouvrir une chaîne youtube et faire exactement ces titres-là en vidéo il n'y aura pas de souci ça marchera
mais c'est vraiment traité comme ça donc avec un point de vue scientifique
mais de manière très drôle
je vais vous en lire un particulièrement qui s'appelle le nombre d'or n'existe pas et comme à chaque chapitre il y a deux informations
d'abord à qui le raconter donc là c'est plutôt
à des architectes parce que je vous rappelle que le fin du titre du livre c'est pour
estomaquer ceux qui se la raconte trop
donc on raconte cette anecdote à des architectes et l' indice de geekerie à quel point tu es geek si tu racontes ça je trouve
ça quand même vraiment très drôle comme approche donc tu reviens sur tout l'historique du nombre d'or
toutes les légendes urbaines aussi qui est un petit peu autour
et vous allez vite vous rendre compte que là en l'occurrence pour ce chapitre là c'est pour ça que je le lis pas ce que
je dévoile rien ça c'est un canular il va revenir sur l'approximation du nombre d'or en fait le nombre d'or n'existe pas dans l'architecture
au sens propre du terme c'est pour ça qu'il faut racontez ça des
architectes parce que c'est un nombre irrationnel et transcendant dire que après la virgule ça va jusqu'à l'infini et ce n'est jamais cycliques
et on ne peut donc
matériellement pas reproduire exactement le nombre d'or on sera toujours sur un arrondi genre
1,680 alors au lieu de 1,6 8 1 3 et je crois que je l'ais mal dis donc quand même je vais le redire
le nombre d'or c'est un 1,6180
ça c'est l'arrondi qu'on utilise le plus souvent et après tu met le trois et ce qui va derrière si tu as envie mais du
coup les architectes ne peuvent pas nier que réellement dans leur architecture le nombre d'or
exact n'existe jamais oui c'est du trolling pour architecte j'aime bien l'idée donc après autant il est intéressant ce nombre d'or
autant il y a vraiment beaucoup de légendes urbaines sur les proportions du corps humain sur certains tableaux sur certaines architectures
qui perdurent encore aujourd'hui
et je trouve ça drôle de pouvoir faire un canular dessus parce que ça dénonce un petit peu je vous propose aussi
l'un des exercices. En fait c'est une devinette
qui propose à la fin ce sont les 100 premiers nombres naturels
classés dans un ordre précis je vous les lis et vous devez trouver dans quel ordre ils sont classés ok ?
100, 5, 50, 55, 52, 51, 58, 59, 54, 57, 56, 53, 2, 10,
18, 19, 17, 12, 8, 9, 11,
on peut s'arrêter là je vous laisse avec ça
dans quel ordre sont classés les nombres et les chiffres que je viens de vous donner vous pouvez donner votre réponse dans les commentaires
et je vous donnerai la réponse dans la vidéo de demain
en plus je vous mets un lien vers vers vers tous les bouquins, les anciens tomes dont je vous ai déjà parlé et le nouveau si ça vous intéresse
dans la description vous le trouverez facilement puisqu'il est juste en dessous du lien pour
réserver vos places pour l'Olympia qui pourrait être une
super idée de cadeau de Noël aussi pourquoi pas. Comme d'habitude vous pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air, vous abonner à la chaîne
à très bientôt, c'est à dire demain matin à 6 heures du matin. Merci à vous, à toi et surtout à toi ciao
*musique*